voà une analyse très détaillée
passionnante en tout cas quel travail
docteur Tisseron alors simplement si
j'ai bien compris votre livre c'est
c'est le capitaine adoc qui est le
centre de tout dans ces histoires de
Tintin oui et pour plusieurs raisons
d'ailleurs HERG a dit que le capitaine
hadoc était le personnage qu'il
représentait c'est vrai que le capitaine
hadoc est le personnage qui évolue le
plus dans les aventures c'est un
personnage qui est plein d'émotion de
joie de colère et c'est un personnage
surtout donc qui évolue et qui passe
d'un d'une situation de d'alcool grand
alcoolique d'alcoolique dangereux hein
il menace Tintin dans le travau pince
d'or et c'est un personnage qui petit à
petit donc devient le cher vieux
capitaine ce personnage très sympathique
qu'on connaît bien qui dans tout le
monde a plaisir à retrouver l'image et
je crois que ce qui est très fort cherg
c'est que RG met en parallèle cette
évolution du capitaine hadoc avec comme
je vous montrais tout à l'heure l'é la
recherche que le capitaine hadoc fait de
son ancêtre et ça c'était dans les
années 50 c'était bien avant le la mode
actuelle de la recherche gén galogique
et je crois qu'erg là a été très fort
monque al oui finalement pour vous tous
les albums de Tintin ne forment qu'une
seule œuvre avec une énigme au début et
la solution de cette énigme à la fin car
pour vous la clé de l'énigme c'est dans
la casse Fiore tout à fait les choses
passe par différents personnages
c'est-à-dire si vous voulez chaque album
un petit peu représente une première
ébauche de la résolution de l'énigme et
je crois que l'énigme est comme vous
dites résolu dans les bijoux de la
castafior d'ailleurs RG dit que c'est à
partir de les bijou de la Casta Fior il
éprouve beaucoup moins le désir de
dessiner pour vous ça dé pas un hasard
non pas du tout euh c'est que je crois
dans les bijoux de la cestafiore RG
arrive à la mise en scène la plus
précise de ce qu'il préoccupait et il
arrive un petit peu de cette façonlà à à
dénouer les inquiétudes qu'il poussait
jusquelà à dessiner parce que RG s'est
toujours décrit lui-même comme un
travailleur acharné quelqu'un de
d'enchaîné à sa table de travail mais
alors quel était le problème d'erger
finalement écoutez le problème d'Erg
justement je ne sais pas quel il était
là je voudrais pas qu'il d'ambigué ce
n'est pas une psychanalyse d'Erg je
crois pas que la psychanalyse mais
n'empêche vous disiez tout à l'heure
HERG pourrait dire finalement le
capitaine adoc c'est moi HERG l'a dit
moi ce qui m'a intéressé ce sur quoi
j'ai voulu travailler c'est de montrer
que l'ensemble de ces albums d nous
effectivement un problème qui était un
problème derger je ne dis pas sans
problème mais qui était surtout le
problème privilégié par le fait de
dessiner si vous voulez j'ai lu autant
les albums de Tintin en psychanalyste
qu'en dessinateur puisque je suis
moi-même un petit peu dessinateur et
j'ai été très intéressé de voir que HERG
finalement fait une mise en scène des
enjeux du geste de dessiner du fait de
dessiner alors vous disiez effectivement
vous êtes unassionné de bande dessiné
c'est vrai vous êtes dessinateur
vous-même mais vous avez fait quelque
chose d'assez étonnant c'est que vous
avez publié votre thèse votre thèse de
médecine de psychiatrie donc sur en
bande dessinée carrément alors est-ce
que ça veut dire que pour vous la bande
dessinée c'est un terrain privilégié
d'étude c'est quoi euh c'est d'abord un
terrain privilégié de plaisir pour moi
et puis c'est devenu un un terrain
privilégié d'étude du fait donc de la
convergence de de mon mon plaisir
d'enfant qui avait été énorme à lire RG
de mon goût pour le dessin et puis de ma
compétence de psychanaliste j'ai trouve
un petit peu de tout merci beaucoup
Serge Tisseron alors je rappelle le
titre de ce livre assez étonnant très
curieux qui s'appelle donc Tintin chez
le psychanalyste c'est publié aux
édition au BIA archimau Serge Tisseron
donc en est l'auteur voilà